if you were in the Army today can I call
you sir today if you were in today no
they're they're you know pushing against
that uh when you have the Secretary of
Defense Lloyd Austin who was a retired
four-star general black man by the way
and I served with him at Fort Bragg when
he was he was a colonel and and uh he
had a brigade and 82nd Airborne Division
everyone looked up to him
but I don't know who this guy is now
when you are the Secretary of Defense
and you're writing a letter uh to the to
the force that says female troops have
to be prepared to be in shower and
bathroom facilities with biological
males did he wrote a letter he wrote a
memo you can you can find it you can he
wrote a memo on that Robert can you find
this memo that's that he wrote Austin
Secretary of Defense the member that he
sent out and you know the the United
States Marines there was a study that
was done I think a University of
Pennsylvania saying that you know you
should move away from calling people sir
and ma'am because that's affirming their
gender and maybe they want to have their
gender affirmed so just call them by
their Rank and their last name don't
call them about it first name you know
it this this is the type of stuff that's
happening in our military now that when
you knew this guy was he a heavyweight
tough guy strong leader was he his call
sign was Panther six I mean he is the
original black panther okay that's how
we saw him so what happened to him so
what happened what happened show an
image of him by the way so people can
get a good look at what what happens is
that
your last promotion in the military as
an officer Congress you need to well no
the last promotion is Brigadier general
or one star that's my little general
that's a one-star yeah that's that's
when you're uh uh you know your peers
two star three star four stars all
political points and so what you end up
finding out is guys who want to continue
on at that that level
end up surrendering to the political
whims and and the administration of the
time
and that's what the problem is and and
so Barack Obama comes along and all of
these generals that were there he says
you either get along with my agenda or
you're gone and that was a big thing
that people were writing about the
purging of senior level leadership in
the military doing the Barack Obama
administration and so all of a sudden
you get these type of generals and if
there's one thing that Donald Trump did
not understand
he had to clean house
he had to clean house in every single uh
government agency you know not just
cabinet position but five six maybe
seven tiers down
and he did not get that and so that's
why you have these people like a general
Miller he's still hanging around and
some of the things he's doing I mean a
United States Journal saying you know
before a a hearing in Congress that you
know I want to study and understand what
white rage is
you know what you're supposed to be
doing is making sure that we can deploy
we can fight we can win that's it none
of this you know cultural Marxism and
and meanwhile if you're the enemy with
with seeing uh today XI and Putin coming
together saying the next hundred years
is going to be epic I'm paraphrasing but
they use the certain words saying what
the next hundred years are going to be
how do you think the enemy if we look at
some of our enemy let's say Iran let's
say China let's say Russia how do they
view America when they see the military
getting this soft we're weak and and
this is the wind of opportunity that
they they have sat around and waited for
that's why the world is more
Machiavellian than ever before everyone
sees this is the opportunity where I can
rise up so when you see what happened in
Afghanistan that's a green light and
think about this uh there would not be
this conflagration in Ukraine if there
had not been in Afghanistan China would
not be threatened in Taiwan if they had
not seen what's happened in Afghanistan
when you leave 80 something billion
dollars of military equipment over there
and I spent two and a half years in
Afghanistan this is U.S military
equipment that you left yes they're
going to figure out a way to back
engineer that and they're going to make
it operational and that's exactly what
they see happening so they see weakness
and China has the one belt one road
strategy which talks about their
hegemonic dominance and you guys are
sitting here in South Florida okay guess
what not too far away here in the
Bahamas China's building Port facilities
in the Bahamas yes my wife is Jamaican
okay you go down to the the new cruise
port facility in in Jamaica it was built
by the Chinese they're all over the
place they're in our hemisphere because
they see this as a time and China
understands that we did not defeat the
Soviet Union militarily
we defeated the Soviet Union
economically
and so when we all of a sudden believe
that we're going to allow China to come
into you know most favorite trade Nation
status bring them into the world
economic uh Community they saw that as a
window of opportunity to let's become
the tick that implants ourselves into
Western Civilization let's you know send
them all the cheap goods and everything
like that you know once upon a time we
had a problem with Chinese drywall right
here in South Florida killing people
they're they're killing us the fentanyl
this is a chemical war that we're in you
know being aided embedded by the the
drug cartels who are terrorist
organization so yes Russia China Iran
North Korea Islamic jihadism they all
see this as an opportunity I know that
you want to talk about the oil and gas
issue that's another issue that they see
that they can rise above us why would we
destroy our own energy Independence
why would we want to make ourselves
subservient once again to the OPEC plus
Nations and so instead of using our oil
and gas that we have here in abundance
to export that not only for our own
independence but to export that and to
undermine the revenues and resources
that these guys have now we have cut
ourselves off of the kneecap and they
see okay well let's uh let's jump in
here as well and now we're going and
begging the Saudis and so uh no by the
way who was down you know broken an
agreement between the Saudi arabias and
uh and Iran Xi Jinping so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign